hallo mein name ist super herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
vielleicht wisst hatte ich vor einigen
wochen fantreffen in wien und da haben
mir sehr viele leute sehr viele
geschenke gegeben und die wollten dass
ich das in dem video zeige ja ich hatte
euch dann gefragt ob ich das ganze
einfach mal am cut auspacken soll weil
das sind drei riesige müllsäcke voll mit
sachen waren darunter meinten halt alle
so jung dass wir voll geil mal so
richtig langes video von dirk bach ohne
katz allerdings habe ich ja die tage ein
video gemacht zu einem streik den ich
bekomme das video fertig meinte
draufklicken erkläre ich genau was das
für main kanal bedeutet was überhaupt
ein streik ist et cetera pp und dieser
tolle streiff bzw
diese verwarnung von youtube schränkt
mich jetzt in der video längeren das
heißt meine video länge ist jetzt
limitiert auf 15 minuten das heißt ich
dürfte jetzt kein video hochladen wo ich
beispielsweise 30 minuten lang nur
geschenke auspacken
deswegen werde ich jetzt doch schneiden
die ganzen geschenke die ich bekommen
habe habe ich aufgeteilt in drei
verschiedene bereiche erstens ein
riesiger müllsack voll mit süßigkeiten
das ist dieser hoshi hier also der
wobei der beatles quasi komplett voll
mit süßigkeiten zweite sache fan
geschenke das ist dieser komplette
pappkarton hier voll mit stofftieren
bilderrahmen ukulelen alt parkuhren und
die dritte kategorie briefe wir sind
unglücklich viele briefe zeichnungen
fotoalben ganz ganz viele briefe
zeichnungen fotoalben fan geschenke alle
locker 400 stück und so werde ich das
ganze video quasi strukturieren dass ich
erst kurz die süßigkeiten zeige dann den
hauptteil damit beschließen den ganzen
verein geschenken chrysler auszupacken
und dann habe ich noch kurz auf die
briefe eingehen weil bei den briefen
wurden mir halt unglaublich viele
instagram namen und auch sehr viele vor
sehr sehr viele mädels haben tatsächlich
ihre handynummer gegeben
also ihr braucht keine hoffnung haben
dass ich euch dann schreibe weil dadurch
habt ihr auch meine nummer und deswegen
das ist seine sache so bei mir
handynummer angegeben werden denke ich
mir wieso geht die möhre handynummer
kennt mich gar nicht ich deswegen will
ich das nicht einen haupt das soll also
ich möchte den zeichnungen und briefen
nicht so viel aufmerksamkeit widmen hier
öffentlich im video weil ich nicht weiß
ob das von den leuten gewollt ist dass
ich die handynummer zeit versteht ihr
was ich meine
einen korb voll mit keksen mit ganze
oder bröselt hier alles runter eine
kopfpauschale mit tomatensaft drin meint
smiley in pigs von mainz miley in sehr
vielen kicks formen melka krebse und
smarties eine messie schokolade wo ich
erst dachte dass ich da auch
unterschreiten sollte es dem zuschauer
zurückgeben habe und jetzt mehr gegeben
hatte meinte das ist für dich deswegen
ist meine unterschrift aus tomatensaft
mit augen ein pizza pappkarton aber mit
keksen drin tomatensaft mit edding augen
mon chéri kirsch pralinen und so
komisches knuspert pulver in tomatensaft
cocktail eine überhaupt nicht süße
weingummi pizza tomatensaft mit einem
auge und einem bananen mund cookies
cookies dann noch tatsächlich cookies
dann haben wir ja auch noch ein paar
cookies und wir haben auch noch cookies
sehr viele cookies tomatensaft mit
irgendwelchen sachen drauf geklebt
prinzenrolle ist auch sehr lecker schon
wieder eine riesige pizza allerdings
diesmal mit sowas saurem weingummi zeugs
schon wieder pralinen und auch
irgendwelche komischen dreck pixar dass
er weg streichelt er danke
willst du dir haben das hier sind die
sachen die ich bereits ausgepackt habe
und hier drin ist halt noch so kleinen
fans also noch soviel zusammenpacken
keys mit und soja keks und übrigens auch
dank an die person die mir diesen
verschimmelten topf tomatensaft
geschenkt also darüber habe ich mich
wirklich sehr gefreut jesus an meiner
hand ich mein können wir nicht als neuen
insider mal irgendwie diamant einen
förderscheck mir nächstes mal diamanten
wäre doch vielleicht auch so eine sache
hat deine schnauze sagt
ist zwar nicht vom fan treffen wurde mir
allerdings so zugesendet und zwar eine
eine ukulele heißt sie glaube ich ist
auch noch funktionstüchtig hat hier
sogar so wimpern und haare und ein
nachbau von ukulele der auch keineswegs
verstimmt ist eine funktionierende
ukulele uhr sogar mit batterie von von
maxi danke maxit übrigens sorry falls
ich hier keine namen vorleser aber es
ist einfach so dass wir so viele sachen
geschenkt wurden und es wurde alles
einfach im korb geschmissen und da sind
häufige zeitlichen jetzt rum hergeflogen
deswegen danke an euch alle aber ich
glaube wenn ihr es mir geschenkt habt
seht ihr das ist hier zeige ja eine tüte
mit einem smiley und einer super
funktioniert halbwegs ein bilderrahmen
mit allen meinen freunden drehen einen
tomatensaft buch mit ganz ganz vielen
sachen rein geschrieben ich weiß nicht
wieso das bei den fans schenken mit drin
ist aber so was habe ich eigentlich in
dieser brief verkürzte da unten wozu ich
am ende noch komme ein bilderrahmen mit
alpakas tomatensaft pizza et cetera und
allen rahmen mit dem controller smiley
ein kompletter weil mit verschiedenen
sachen drauf gemalt ein großer
bilderrahmen bezeichnungen von mir eine
box mit 100 fakten über mich an allen
möglichen stellen angebracht ein nutella
glas und eine trommel im luca beklebt
sachen style ein voll bemaltes blue
shampoo und mit max und unten und mir
tatsächlich seifenblasen und einen cent
ods spiel und ich glaube das kommt sogar
von der person die mir auch die ukulele
gebastelt hat eine flasche tomatensaft
eingepackt mit komischen bildchen von
mir ein minecraft scharf und ein t shirt
ein bedrucktes t-shirt mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen grimassen von mir das hier
ich es ist es unbeschreiblich weiß nicht
was darstellen soll aber danke eine
ente die glaube ich leuchte daran sie
irgendwo liegt katar und leuchtet einen
nerv das ist übrigens alles von der
person die mir auch die ukulele
gebastelt und ein komisches t shirt mit
hunden drauf also auch danke dafür aber
denke ich werde ich eher nicht abziehen
das sind alles stofftiere die mir
geschenkt wurden
ich werde jetzt einmal im
schnelldurchlauf durchgehend ein kleiner
pudel namen schneeflöckchen ein alpaka
noch ein alpaka noch ein alpaka noch ein
alpaka noch ein alpaka und noch ein
alpaka namens call my name is khan und
eines t shirt an und das ist dass ist
karl eingenäht akon crafter minecraft
figur stofftier dings ein häschen was
aus einer karotte raus schlüpft ein
selbstgenähtes einhorn ein sehr
schwieriges einhorn ein hund noch ein
hund noch einen noch ein hund noch ein
hund ein panda und noch zwei eulen
wir wurden wirklich sehr viele
zeichnungen briefe cetera gegeben ihr
als bekannt wie der zeichnung
mit ganz vielen gemalten bildern drin
der zeitungen zeit nehmen
doch mitmachen ganz der politik
ich finde das ultra cool ich habe mir
alles angeschaut als ich in den korb
gepackt hat und quasi alles sortiert
habe die sache ist halt dank er an
jacqueline kathrin marx alle an
das sind die einzigen namen behalten
konnte eine riesen dankeschön an alle
von euch allerdings weiß ich nicht ob
ihr wollt dass ich die sachen hier zeige
weil bei manchen steht halterin luca ich
war teilweise echte nach daun fahrt
meinem leben und deine videos habe ich
voll gerettet das ultra süß zu lesen
aber das ist jetzt nichts was wo ich
öffentlich den brief wird zeigen möchte
ich weiß viele von euch zuschauern und
vielleicht sogar feingold ezb grad
würden sich jetzt wünschen dass sich das
zeige allerdings weiß ich nicht ob ich
das von allen machen soll deswegen sage
ich jetzt einfach das ist das ende von
video video mit br neuerdings ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen ich bin euch
dankbar für alle süßigkeiten kekse
pizzen kaffeeautomaten seinen kollegen
die mir gebastelt wurden an die 7000
packers und stofftiere die mir geschenkt
wurden an die tausenden bilder briefe
glückwünsche zu meinem geburtstag zu
allem ich bin euch wirklich sehr dankbar
auch wenn es vielleicht im video grad
nicht so rüberkommt ich würde am
liebsten bei jedem gegenstand zehn jahre
reden allerdings gibt das die zeit
einfach nicht ja ich hoffe ich bin ich
über 15 minuten gekommen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat will
ich mich über eine bewertung freund
schreibt man die kommentare ob ihr
geschenk gesehen hat und wir sehen uns
vielleicht von anders wieder auf 1